chase Edmunds here running back Arizona
Carlos future GM that y'all know yet I'm
rethinking it from the all-time 49er
squad all-time Chiefs current 49ers
current Chiefs of how I build my team
[Music]
first and foremost speed all these kills
I need time to kill Sansa's player to
need to strap up I need it
second to me in my opinion best
quarterback in NFL right now I need
Patti by I'm cheap so I got my four
dollars right now I got 11 left I'm
going to defense side the ball a future
hall-of-famer Richard Sherman you can
play me Maggie playing his own I like
him okay yes I got eight left
I think I'm gonna go to a for-sure
target I can't believe he's only $2 Wow
best tight end in the game probably
arguably ever I got six left hmm I got
to get to the quarterback
I'm gonna go Derek Thomas I mean I kinda
wanted Ronny the files to me for the
safeties a lot and Joe Montana
I was just all-time great but I'm gonna
stick with Patti moans and I think he's
the most talented quarterback to ever
touch the ball so I got one dollar left
for y'all
this isn't an emergency yeah I'm saying
put in my back pocket Tom bajalia still
might like that but that's my part right
there baby so speed always kills you
can't teach it
sorry killed make a cheetah's especially
God ever strap up Elvis in these like
duck gah Pachamama John quarterback
franchise type I think he's a part most
talented to ever touch a ball outside of
Dan Marino maybe lock down corner of
Richard Sherman future hall-of-famer
that says enough quarterback the best
friend Tony Gonzalez one of the best
fighters ever and he somebody get some
quarterback man always this is chase
atmosphere this is no just squat best
squat anybody can get it Patti cheetah
mr. Sherman
Tony G Derek Thomas
[Music]